it's pretty
[Music]
pretty flattering so far although i
don't think there's any
any doubt that i should be leading based
on the games that we have so far
okay so let's see what he's got
okay it goes for
goes for the old italian
um
uh he wants to line that with knight f6
d4
clearly
what should i do about that
um
well don't think for half a minute
that is probably a number one okay let
me
do something very unusual here
okay he doesn't go he certainly should
have gone d4 i was intending to
to take on d4 and then go bishop b6
which is a bad line but it's not
like extremely bad if white doesn't know
what he's doing
so here i'll just play standard stuff
and i wasted
wasted a bunch of time but i think it
will be fine
castle
there are subtleties here but i don't
know if it matters
really don't
okay now he does exploit my uh
my refusal to go for um
oh that is it that is the point
then i've probably been a very silly boy
by allowing all of this
ah that was the point okay
um don't think there's disaster quite
yet because the e5 can be answered by
knight g4
but i am in some danger here
okay h3 let's just
try and be active compensate for
some of the time lost
if he takes everything on on e5 and then
bishop a3
d2 is hanging it takes and then
yeah so we intends knight c4 so
i'll get i guess i'll go queen of six
it seems very reasonable
unless there is
so the idea of queen f6 is knight c4
that i can take on h3
but i was thinking about queen of f6
maybe as
g3 then
uh yeah whatever
we'll go and f6 g3 i was hoping there
might be some
tactics along the lines of taking on d4
and and so on okay so he goes for queen
deep one instead
which i guess is fairly fairly clever
yeah knight f4 knight c4
i'm sort of struggling to find a good
response there
i could take the pawn on d4 but i really
really don't want to
okay i don't i don't have a choice
it's not a four knight c4 just look
really ugly
my counter play was not really going
anywhere
okay so we
we go for this instead if if e5 i have
to take
f2 but i don't know
beggars can't be juicers don't think
don't think it works at all but
i didn't see what else to do
huh yeah
didn't see what else to do
rk3 i was hoping that knight e4
knight d3 and taking rock would not lose
immediately but maybe this is
this is just much better
this is really really bad
point now if he takes everything on e5 i
have queen c5 check and take on c1 and
a3 also hangs
so at least in that line i'm not losing
on the spot
that's about the only positive thing you
can say
oh maybe i'm losing on the spot
yeah no no way to protect that knight i
think
okay this this one is a loss
right now i'm sure he's just savoring
the moment
i mean anything is winning bishop d2
bishop h6 as well was winning
okay whatever that was just awful
uh really really disappointing that i
i couldn't but i couldn't clip
keep a clean sheet one thing is the
sweep
but the clean sheet seemed
a lot more attainable so now let me
let me just try and focus and um
try and win another game to get the get
to get the match over with